Kabuki, Quantum Fighter, Earth, the Future.
And welcome to NEStalgia, a chronological exploration of every NES game released in North America.
I'm Mike. I'm Sean.
And I'm Joe.
And was the back of the box just like random words?
Yeah, you're right. It's like Earth, the future.
I don't have the back of the box present right now, but I know I specifically picked that just to fool around with the back of the box.
There was a lot more like plot details, but then it was just one sentence that said Earth, the future.
And I was like, yeah, let's fucking go with that.
Like, that sounds awesome.
So it's not really either the beginning or the end of the back of the box.
It was in there, but I picked it.
And that's the rules.
You're allowed to do that. You should just pick like a bunch of random letters and rearrange them into whatever words we want to say.
Yeah. I mean, is anybody really ready for the future?
Not 2054.
2056. Come on, Joe.
I'm not ready for that. Joe, Jesus Christ.
Did you even play the game?
I played the prequel.
It's so 2056 coded that I don't know how you missed that.
Yeah, but it is Kabuki Quantum Fighter.
It's 2056.
A rogue virus has hijacked the planet's defense supercomputer.
Interesting that it's just supercomputer.
Like, there's just one. Well, it's the supercomputer.
Like, the rest of them are just like regular computer.
What happened? Did one company win?
Like, right now, we're in a state where, like, every company is building their own supercomputer or data center or whatever.
Is there going to be?
So, there would be data centers, but this is just supercomputer with no S.
Well, basically, over enough time, and I guess the 30 years until whatever year that was, is enough time for them all to sort of grow together.
And then here's the problem.
That defense supercomputer, it's the one controlling the nuclear weapons.
It didn't even have a password.
Right. Yeah, no nuclear codes.
The nuclear weapons themselves are being controlled by the computer.
And it seems like basically all everything, they've run out of options.
So, they're going to upload you, the player character's consciousness, directly into this machine as binary data and fight the virus from the inside.
This kind of sounds a little relevant to what's going on today, right?
Like, we're a couple of years away.
Maybe it doesn't even take until 2056 before we start uploading consciousness into the clawed to fight back.
Ugh.
It's got a little bit more nuance than that.
I appreciate that.
Yeah, I liked it, too.
I mean, I can't pretend that it's not just one giant exposition dump.
But, like, I was invested.
You know, it was, you know, it got me.
And the player characters is Colonel Scott O'Connor.
Scott Connor.
That's kind of, Sean, you mentioned the Terminator reference.
That's kind of close.
Yeah. To the Connors of the Terminator universe.
And when he enters, like, how does it work?
Does his mind enter the computer?
Is he physically in the computer?
I think. Does he know how to control the body?
I don't think he's physically in there. Isn't he in that, like, he's, like, laying in that.
He's in that. Yes, he's laying in that thing.
He was, like, an image of his brain was made.
Right. And his, like, consciousness has been copied into the computer and is now doing the thing.
Do you think all of our consciousnesses have, like, that hair?
Yeah, let's go.
Now, here's the interesting thing.
Did you know that when he entered that system, the system used a image of his great-great-grandfather,
who was a Japanese kabuki actor?
And so your digital avatar fights with the traditional costume, white face paint, and extremely long red hair of a traditional kabuki actor?
And they do bring this up in that intro movie, and they just sort of, like, yeah, that's normal.
Like, oh, wasn't... Yeah, that'll happen.
Wasn't his great-great-great-grandfather doing that?
Yeah, does that mean that this guy's great-great-grandfather was, like, somehow just, like, deeply embedded in this guy's subconscious?
Or was it just, like, no, no, it's like an Assassin's Creed thing where, like, your DNA has memory?
Was that a big thing in Ireland?
I think it's the Assassin's Creed thing. In what?
Was kabuki, like, really big in Ireland?
Why Ireland? His name is O'Connor.
Oh, right, right, right. Yeah, that's good.
Very good. But wait, yeah, no, of course.
Kabuki, do they, like, fight with their hair?
No, never. But they just happen to have long hair.
Yeah, yeah. Because, honestly, the, like, fighting with your hair thing, we didn't mention it, but you fight with your hair.
Yeah, he's bayonet. It's so silly and also so cool to me at the same time.
I love it. It actually is convincing, too, like, the animation for it and everything.
Like, I believe that those whips of the hair are doing significant damage, at least in a digital world.
It should be doing damage to yourself as well, though, like, with the whiplash.
Yeah, but when it's your digital body, you don't have to worry about your digital bones.
Is there not, like, digital CTE?
There actually probably is, right?
But who's simulating that?
Is it the AI? Because why can't the AI just simulate him feeling bad?
Yeah, the AI should just be, like, running the sadness program on him as a defense.
And, like, this is not realistic.
I think that the AI is trying, like, it's, you know, this is all it trying to get a hold of this program so it can run whatever it wants to.
It's like a, it's like your computer trying to locate a virus, you know?
Right, right. I think that's what all these enemies are, are parts of the AI trying to do it.
So don't worry, we got that covered. They're the white blood cells.
Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
This was developed by Human Entertainment.
We always like to call them out because that's just, it's perfect when they make especially games about AI and call themselves Human Entertainment.
But published by HAL Laboratory, you know, the Kirby and Smash Brothers people.
So I don't really know if it has any of that DNA, but we've seen some other games from them before.
I think, you know, the manual and certainly, like, everything we've been talking about so far commits hard to this, like, science of consciousness being uploaded to an AI framework.
And then, as Joe mentioned, the avatar fights with his hair.
So there's, like, this gap between the game's pretensions and its reality.
And I think that's actually where the charm comes from because the gameplay itself is actually kind of fun.
As a result, it's just really silly that the plot is so serious, but the game is actually kind of whimsical.
Yeah, but I also think that the seriousness of the plot can sometimes be read as, like, over-the-top, like, cool.
You know, over-the-top cool in the sense where it's almost a parody.
I know it's not, but it feels that way.
Like, I feel like if it were made today, it would be parodying games like this.
So, like, I kind of read it as, like, oh, this is, like, so fun because it's, like, trying to be so crazy serious and it's not.
It's kind of like how, you know, the costume design in The Matrix was cool.
And now, whenever you see somebody like that, they're usually, like, dancing to, like, goth electronica under a bridge.
Right, right.
And, you know, I think it's obviously done on purpose that it's mixing a very old art form in Kabuki with a futuristic outlook with AI and uploading your consciousness into a machine.
And even the title, like, Kabuki Quantum next to each other is pretty crazy.
You seem to be a little worried about the consciousness angle.
I don't think I'm worried about it.
I think it's, like, just a neat approach to then, like, to take a very traditional, exclusive to Japanese art form of Kabuki theater and then, like, bring that over to America.
Like, they surely could have.
They didn't have to keep that part.
They could have localized it a little bit.
Yeah, I'm surprised that they didn't change the...
Because everything else is so sci-fi.
And then you just got the sky.
The coolest thing about maybe the aesthetic of the game, though, is that before you even take control of the character and start playing the game, the game opens on a wall of text of what looks like real assembly code.
You know, showing instructions of the game, the game opens on a wall of text of what looks like real assembly, the game opens on a wall of text of what looks like real assembly.
But I don't...
You see it a lot more now, like, with, like, glitchiness as just an aesthetic choice.
And I wasn't expecting something like that.
So it was a cool touch.
I appreciated it.
And I'm certainly no expert on Kabuki theater.
But outside of the main character, I don't think there's any other part of the identity of that in this game.
So I'm sure that the face paint and the clothing is all accurate to the Kabuki time period.
But otherwise, that's it for the game, right?
Yeah, I guess we'd have to zoom in a bit to tell if it was period accurate.
No, yeah, sure.
But even just the idea of it, it's only in the way that the character looks.
Right. Not even in, like, the enemies or the...
It doesn't feel like you're part of a stage play.
Right. In Kabuki theater, that's the one where, like, there's the percussion, right?
Masks. Like, really, like... Yeah.
But right, there's that, like, really, like, I don't know, that distinct sounding percussion, right?
Yes, that's true. It would have been nice if there was, like, a character theme that had that or something.
And then the environments themselves, I wouldn't say they don't look nothing like a computer,
but they're certainly not what I would think the inside of a computer would look like.
It looks more like a biological corruption of a computer.
Like, there are living, breathing parts of this thing.
There's one screen where there's just a bunch of...
Not just one, but a bunch of beating hearts and stuff.
It looks like...
Or, you know...
It's very alive.
And maybe that's on purpose, but you would expect maybe more circuit boards and things of that, not body horror machinery.
Like, yeah. It kind of jumps back and forth between stages.
And some of them are even just like, oh, it's just all bones.
All bones everywhere.
But, again, like, I don't think that the original...
That this game, like, was supposed to be about this originally.
Like, the Japanese version, at least.
So I'm just supposed to give it a pass?
No, I'm saying that, like, it just makes sense that it doesn't do that.
See, you got it. Yeah, and I, like...
Because I almost... I wouldn't say that I wouldn't...
Necessarily that I wouldn't expect all the biological stuff.
It's that... Or that I would expect...
I'm sorry. I wouldn't say that I would expect there to be more circuit boards.
It's that I would expect there not to be the biological stuff.
Because there are circuit boards.
And it does feel like that.
But then, yeah, it's like...
It's almost like the computer was corrupted by an alien.
Or something. Ooh.
Yeah, I mean...
It looks more like dark fantasy than cyberpunk.
But maybe it was a deliberate metaphor for a biological virus entering the AI.
You know, maybe the...
Maybe even though it wasn't intentional, as Sean's trying to point out, it could be interpreted that way.
So to get into the combat, we have, obviously, the hair-based combat.
Oddly, though, when you crouch, you don't then, like, crouch and whip your hair.
You resort to your punches.
So you are capable of punching.
You are capable of dealing damage that way.
You just choose to attack with your hair.
What is the range like?
Well, the hair is way better than punching.
For sure.
Which, it bothered me a little bit.
Like, I just want to use my hair when I'm crouching.
But I wonder if the punching is in there.
Have you tried head-binging while you're crouching?
In real life?
Yeah. This is what makes it realistic.
No, that... I can head-bing while I crouch.
That's the only time I do it.
But I... Yeah, the only reason I could think of that they would put the punching when you're crouching
is maybe to make you appreciate the reach of the hair.
And be like, oh, yeah, see, that's why we're using the hair.
It's so much better than the punching.
Yeah, it feels crunchier, too.
There's a little bit of a delay.
Or at least you kind of have to let the animation play out.
And that, coupled with the fact that it does more damage, at least it feels like a better tactic.
And your other button is for jumping, which, of course, there are platforms and such.
But there are also hooks built into the walls, I guess.
Maybe they're floating.
It's a computer.
Anything can happen, I suppose.
There's these hooks that you can grab onto, and they allow you to swing.
And you can just tap A for a short swing or hold down for a full arc.
That gets a little tricky, especially when there's a lot of hooks and a long way to fall down.
I noticed that sometimes I would just instinctually, when I grabbed onto the next hook, begin to start swinging from it
and then leap off of it, most likely into an enemy that I didn't intend to.
But there is also, you know, he has a little bit of that Ninja Gaiden wall climbing ability as well.
You'll see more hook swinging than you will wall climbing, but they're both present and spice up the platforming.
And it's not to say that these stages are, you know, they're more horizontal side scrollers than they are vertical,
but they do scale up a lot.
And the idea of, like, having branching paths isn't there, but there are, like, different ways to approach.
There isn't always just the one way up.
Yeah, and you think it's a hot take for me to say that I think the way these hooks work
is how I wish the grappling hook worked in Bionic Commando.
Ooh. Like, I just feel like this is how I want that to feel.
Yeah, no, it is smooth.
It just feels smooth. Yeah.
And it, like, makes you feel pretty badass the whole time.
Like, I'm never, like, oh, I got to stop and think, how does this work again?
It's just kind of, like, it's just kind of intuitive after you kind of get the hang of it.
Yeah, I think the one thing I wasn't ready for, though, is just, like, letting go of the A button
when you land on the next one in order to just hang there.
Like, for some reason, because you're holding down A from the swing and you're releasing,
when I get to the next one, my instinct is to then press A again to, like, confirm it.
Not to, you know, not to let go of it.
There was some times where I just unintentionally fell to damage or death because I was still getting
the hang of it. But over time, you get the hang of it.
And, you know, there's a lot of, I don't want to say random, but there's a lot of drops
in the vertical sections of this game where you kind of have to do a little bit of a leap
of faith and just, you know, you'll land unknowingly into spikes or enemies or into,
there's those, like, pools of water that push you into spikes.
Like, it's not ideal.
Especially when there's enemies.
It's like, you knew I had to fall into this area.
You know I can't see what's below it.
There's no option to, like, crouch and look down and, like, expand a little bit of the
screen. So why place an enemy, like, right there?
Like, you'd have to know it's in the stage after playing a few times in order to avoid
it. It's all punishment, Mike.
Oh, right. Why didn't I?
Yeah, it's the AI punishing.
Yes. Everything in this game is actually flawless because a computer designed it.
And it's designed to make you feel the way you're feeling.
Filled with dread about consciousness.
Uh, how fair things are.
Uh, how cool long red hair is.
Wait, you feel the dread about that?
Or that's just a separate thought?
No, no, that's just sort of the same.
It's a separate thought, yeah.
I just felt like the enemy placement, even, not even just in areas you can't see, but just
in general, could have been a little better.
And while you have, uh, your hair to rely on, there are other attacks you can do by switching
to them using, uh, so you have two, uh, bars.
You have a life bar, which obviously is your standard HP.
And then you have this chip bar, uh, that you, uh, don't necessarily have maxed out, but
you can gain as you go along by collecting, uh, pickups.
The chip system use, if you use your hair, it doesn't cost any chips.
But if you use some of the other, um, weapons that you unlock after you defeat a boss, uh,
basically it's, it think, think like Mega Man style, except for you're not choosing the
stages. Uh, you just go beat the boss and then you acquire a new weapon and then you can use
that at, at will, uh, by, by pressing the select button to switch to the new, uh, weapon.
Those weapons have limited use though, because, uh, once you run out of chip, you'll, um, you'll,
I got your hair to go back to the hair.
Yeah. You only got your hair to rely on.
I didn't actually notice this at first.
It wasn't until later, uh, like level two that I realized that in the UI, there is a
little thing that shows that your hair is selected.
Right. It looks like a, it looks like a fireball.
Yeah, exactly. And I'm like, Oh, so I use, I use select and I'm like, Oh, I've got a little like pea
shooter now. And then I press select again.
And then I guess at that point I'd unlocked like a slightly more powerful projectile and
it uses a lot of chip.
So I ended up just really saving that stuff for bosses.
I mostly did too.
Although, you know, there were times, I think like in, in the, you know, like stage three
or three and four, I did kind of realize, Oh, I can use these early on because I get
enough chip back like halfway through the level before I get to the boss.
It is kind of random how you get chip back though.
So yeah, I mean, they're just drops from enemies, right?
Yeah. It's just, yeah.
So like, I feel like I felt safe in that, like, Oh, I'll get some if I like only use
this in the first half of the stage or something.
But honestly, I think your hair is one of the better options to, for like a lot of just
like the main running through using the enemies, because you don't have to like think about
what it is. Because I think like some, I think the, the, the power ups feel like they are best suited
for the bosses anyways.
Like, so I, so it was, it ended up like not feeling like too much of a downer to have to
save it for the bosses.
Cause I think I would have, a lot of the times would have chosen the hair anyways in the
main levels. Yeah.
Cause the game is, it feels designed for melee.
Designed for hair. Yeah.
Yes. Melee hair.
This is a hair metal game.
Yeah. the chip system even though the drops are random it does get around this thing that we talked about
i feel like a lot when we started the show but uh has come up from time to time of just like
sometimes it's just like why even bother fighting enemies if you can just move past them and it's
like well here it's you want it's this way you have enough chip to go into the boss fights because
the boss fights are certainly challenging uh if you're just using your hair like you're gonna
have a bad time trying to surely you could learn the patterns and do a hair only run of nothing
possible but any percent you know hair only but if you go into a boss battle with full chip health
uh or chip supply and then you have something like the uh i think it's called the fusion gun that does
the uh fireball spread where it shoots uh diagonally up down and straight ahead you could be doing three
hits at a time pretty rapidly against these bosses where otherwise you might have to like try and like
just squeak in a hit with your hair and then go back to defense and wait for their pattern to end and land
in a new place and then attack them again once it's just like it really speeds up those boss fights in a
way that's beneficial to the player now i didn't try this unfortunately i learned about it too late
but apparently did you know that during any boss fight you can pause and press up or down to trade
health for chips what no that's it is a it is a two to one rate so you you can trade and you can trade
in both directions too by the way you can use chips to gain back health but if you're running low on
ammo mid-fight just burn up some hp wait to reload it's two health to one chip and then vice versa if
you do it the other way one one chip to health you you could i guess technically by that math kill
yourself by just yeah unequally sharing between them like going in one direction and then being like
i didn't mean to do that i like the idea of this but i just knowing how much a lot of the uh
weapons take how much chip a lot of the weapons take it almost feels like
yeah it's going to be pretty rare where you're going to have enough life to make a significant
amount of chip right but i guess you know just knowing how powerful the those those chip attacks
are at doing damage to the boss it could be worth even to just trade off once to do enough to have
one more of the uh either the bomb or the spread gun uh at your disposal or that uh what's the one
where like the things just follow it like there's a bunch of little guys that just go follow like
that that was very powerful oh yeah what is that called it was it had a little guys little guys
that's what it was yeah those are your little guys um no what are those i don't know started with a b
started with a b okay i'm looking in the manual now um little guy swarm yeah the remote control bolos
bolo bolo ties perfect that's all just bolo ties that act on their own yeah and so i just want
while i have the manual here i just wanted to see if it actually explained trading your yeah yeah yeah
it does say here in the final page in the it's the final page fighting the bosses if you run low on
energy while battling with bosses you can get more energy by trading your memory chips pause the game by
pressing the select button then use the upper and lower arms of the d-pad nobody says the arms well
they say control pad not d-pad but lower arms of the control pad uh to swap memory chips for energy
if you use this special technique well you should get the results shown below and then it has a picture
sorry can you call that technique show the picture or is that just yeah right feature i think the
technique they were saying is if you just do that feature you should be able to and then it shows
like a boss blown up uh but yeah i think that's interesting but it's kind of again another thing
that's like does everybody know that like the three of us played the game and didn't know that uh i guess
if you know if you have a manual you knew that but did you read all the way to page 17
did you get to the end of the manual did you actually did you actually try a little bit like
did you did you check uh the game that you spend money on did you read the whole thing
yeah it's like well you know it's funny i know that like we talk about enjoying reading the manuals
but do you think you ever actually like read the whole cover yeah cover to cover the manual before
you start playing the game you just read whatever you got up to in the car before you got home yeah but
there's only 17 you never looked at that thing again you can get there i i was far away from my
eb games so oh i had some time yeah if i if i didn't have uh if i hadn't finished the manual yet i
usually have my parents driver on the block a few times so i could finish it yeah i was there did you
guys see the final boss of the game that's as far as i got i got to the final boss of the game i did
not beat the final boss of the game so you've doomed your world yeah i was like you know what that's
fine we'll doom it it's pretty cool it's definitely the most uh like body horror thing we've seen yet
where it has the mechanical biological like you see it's guts at all you're actually fighting on
its guts right like that's the the stage itself like the floor is guts the floor is guts i played
that game yeah we all played oh my god i didn't realize that the floor was like squirmy guts i think
i was just too focused on on it just like lava to me because i wasn't focusing on it and then he's
hooked up to you know the the computer's all hooked up to that and then there's like coming out of the
computer is another like it looks like something out of um salamander but it's uh or life force as
it's called on the nes it's just like another one of those dragon things and it's shooting fireballs at
you while you have to try it and and they you know they were nice though they were nice they gave you
those little uh swinging hooks that we've been talking about there's two of those in this stage
you would think that the boss would be smart enough to remove those by now i did appreciate though uh
that like the design of these bosses did take into account like their little uh platforming
uh the the platforming gimmicks like the penultimate boss like the one before this
is sort of a mech that you can climb on and you gotta climb on top of it to get to the the weak point
and so at least they're taking their their unique things and using them in fun ways in the boss battles
yeah and just zooming out even further i think the boss bet all the boss battles just as a whole in this
game i think really shined for me where like they they've they felt like modern action game boss
battles in the sense where i felt like i was learning their patterns it wasn't just like yeah hit him a
bunch of times before he hits you a bunch of times or like yeah their pattern is it does this and it
does that it's like even the first one was weird that like it had a weird vibe to it because usually
we're used to these big like set piece bosses with that are just giant like pieces of uh horrific
sprite work horrific in a good way um right and he's just a guy like you that kind of has a similar
move set and yeah it feels like he's being controlled by a person in a way and it does he moves fast and he
flips around and he's like yeah it's not like this i don't know there's just something really cool about
the boss being the same size as you in any game but then also uh i think for me the one that like
really got me was i think it was the third stage boss it's like this like green spider robot thing
that climbs on the ceiling and like and there was like there was a lot of pattern to that and it had
two little like minions shooting around you had to kill them first and you had to figure out how to
get it to come down and then you'd have to like hit it while it was down near you and then you know
you'd have to bait it into shooting at you and dodge its attack to get it to come down at you
just like i don't know a level of thinking about how to tackle these bosses that we don't usually see
in nes games the final boss is a little confusing though because it has that small little head jutting
out of its bigger head that the thing that looks like a dragon and that shoots fireballs at you and
when you finally uh deal enough hits to it it uh the head you know blows up i guess a little bit
and then you would think that now you have to fight the bigger head like it's gonna brand it's
gonna like take off from that and float around the screen and do crazy damage or something but it
just continues to spew out from that head that you blew up now it just has a spread attack of three
fireballs and it's like i've never thought of a and i'm joe i'm sure it's challenging i didn't get to it
uh but it doesn't feel like a big climactic final fight when it's just like okay he goes from shooting
one fireball to three fireballs and then the fight's over yeah and like comparatively to the
other bosses it does seem like a little simpler granted there's two stages to it like you kill it
and then it just gets all health back and you know it's headless body it's also like a boss rush at
that point too like you've this is if we're counting phases as separate bosses like this is the third boss
in a row that you fought yeah that's a good point yeah this is like you don't you know you don't want to
make it too challenging at this point because then they got to go all the way back yeah and uh the
reveal of course that the uh computer virus came from outer space whoa it's like what you said
joe yeah i didn't even know yep so how about that joe joe you didn't even know i didn't even know
uh that's explained um i think even i think it comes from the epilogue like after you beat
the the game it has like a very long text driven thing and then a full credits you never you don't
see that usually like listing off who did the design who were the programmers were special thanks
i was in that yeah i saw you thank you you were you were cha-cha maru uh no i was sean
oh my bad keep getting you guys confused well they're spelled the same way that's why yeah yeah
yeah um that silent w i was a little disappointed with the story even though i didn't get to the end
so i didn't know my prediction already but i was disappointed in the story that that it tees up at
the beginning this idea that like and we don't know what'll happen to your mind when you go into
this thing like it'll it can change your whole it can change your whole identities in ways we we can't
predict and like i was like wow this is gonna have like a crazy twist at the end where like you get
absorbed into the virus or like you come out and now you want to take over the world or whatever it's
like they're like oh no i guess we were wrong about that that was just we were just we were just
speculating like there's nothing comes comes from that it like you know i was saying i like it's at
least it's at least a cool concept that isn't the zorblacks coming in from outer space and
but it kind of is uh it just has uh a bit more uh a bit more of a hook in the beginning and then
they just ignore it for the rest of the game right yeah not that this game is um ripe for memes or
anything i don't think it's going to be discovered but if all your base belongs to us can become a
meme i did enjoy that uh the uh scott the kabuki quantum fighter at the end of the game he says this
is scott control room can you hear me and you hit next to confirm and they go uh colonel we had given
you up for the dead and he says i'd like to return to my body now it's just a screen that says that
it's just like his his face all nice pixel art red eyes and everything and he's like i'd like to return
to my body now now if they wanted to take this seriously they'd be like sorry you're a copy you got
to stay there we're gonna delete you soon uh the real scott's over here just asleep um goodbye
after the credits if you hit the b button you get uh to go to a sound test which seems uh you know i've
played uh kirby's i played all the kirby games and that's like a common thing at the end of uh the game
you get to do the sound test uh after you beat the game so that's like a hall laboratory staple but on
that sound test other than just being able to play different music tracks from the game it chose scott
in his kabuki form still and he says i'll be back watch for my next adventure is this the part where
you say that that never happened no sequel was ever made uh this is a standalone curiosity yet
yeah yeah yeah they're working on it i'm sure sakurai is gonna get right on this one
and uh while there is no sequel as sean mentioned uh in the beginning of this episode
this uh the famicom version of this game was a tie-in to the 1990 film zip pang
um and i just i did not watch this movie so i am reading off of um a description here but
the protagonist in that is a 15 year old boy named bobby yano and the threat is a magatama
which is an ancient comet shaped bead from japan folklore yeah bead like or multiple beads beads like
jewelry uh but it typically this is the twist those magatamas typically symbolize good fortune a
protection against evil and a sign of fertility oh uh but but this magatama uh i guess like it's not fertile
it's like it's not good well no it's almost like yeah it's like the black materia in final fantasy 7
it's just like we're facing a comet that's going to destroy uh the earth so no no ai no uh evil virus
from outer space uh well there's still something from space okay yeah space right right space same
thing yeah exactly okay so that they made up the whole like basically sci-fi element aside from sci-fi
element but also i think they made up the kabuki element wait it wasn't like why why add that right
i don't know i'm saying like i didn't watch the movie but i guess like a little kipedia page
and i let's look it up together but to me i i feel like that's not what the movie was i feel like
there's gonna turn out that there was like a scene where they mentioned kabuki and they like had to
you know how like they these games always work in the most random thing from the movie
they just like made it the whole theme of the game if i can command f kabuki on zip hang the film
uh which also had a manga uh the only the only uh found is for this game was retitled kabuki
quantum fighter for its western release very strange did he at least have long hair and i'm asking the
wrong person yeah you could you could ask the right person i suppose but uh sean i will just show you
just to give you an idea of what the people uh just show you how far removed we are yeah i'm sending
this to you the users the listeners oh wow the listeners it's all just look up zipang it's not
even close it's just navy men right yeah it's in the navy uh that's what we've got going on here
and they're all like clean cut guys so i don't know where this came from i i do love that we're so
we're so invested in in this but can't be bothered to watch the movie that you are now calling the
listeners the users i know i couldn't believe i did that right
that was my um that was my marketing background
we'll watch the movie someday will we let me know how it is what we will do is the essential games list
joe yeah so as i was playing this even i was like thinking in the lens of like
do we have too many games on the essential games it's like do i want to keep putting games on because
i just i don't want it to get too oversaturated either but i couldn't bring myself to give this a
no vote because i i just really thought this is like one of the one of the best like action
platformer i guess that we played and everything about it feels pretty darn good to me but the the
i mean the way the combat works the way that it feels i love the hooks and the uh like the the
platforming in that sense just felt really good and the boss battles were really easily designed
or really nicely designed rather and i do think this was a little bit of an easier game than um
than a lot of games that we play which and it you know was kind of shorter but it's one of those uh
nice like bite-sized experiences that i feel like you can sit down you can play it in a night
um i don't know i i love the music i loved uh i love the whole thing so i i'm i'm throwing it a vote
sean i uh yeah i i liked a lot about this game i once again have to call out that i appreciate that
the uh that the story is nonsensical but in a like kind of in a fun way um still wrapping my head
around what the movie could have been about but uh that's neither here nor there um yeah solid
action game uh appreciated the platforming elements appreciated the hair attacks uh i like the boss
designs i but i don't know if any of these things like put it over the like the hump of like essentialness
i i think that there's a lot of competency here i think there's a lot of like yeah this is fun to
just sort of play when like you're assigned it in a podcast like will i play this again and i i don't
i don't really know if i'm going to um so i i do think it's a play it um you gotta give credit to
headbanging as an attack but i i don't know if i can put this on the essential games list but mike can
i can uh it would be two to one i will say this about uh kabuki quantum fighter is that uh there
has never been a stranger game title that then led to a uh fun experience uh i reading kabuki i was just
confused in general about like what kind of game we were going to get and the game we got like has
very solid mechanics i really enjoy um playing as scott o'connor as weird as that sounds uh
the the the grabbing of the hooks the swinging the uh the use of your hair whip the additional things
you pick up uh learning about the trading the chips for the life like it's a very uh well thought
out game which is why especially even the boss battles like the boss battles are really cool
which is why i'm so confused about the the level design itself because that's what holds this
game back for me that's what's gonna make me say no and upset joe is that i think you're controlling
an awesome character and you're fighting awesome bosses and the story while being like weird and
sometimes nonsensical is intriguing and keeps me like wondering what's going on but the actual level
design i did not enjoy uh i didn't like you know i mentioned that like some enemies are just placed
in like really inappropriate spots and stuff like that but i also just didn't enjoy that moment to
moment of getting around with the the way that they like a lot of times it was falling through pits
again to then like have to redo a lot of hook swinging sections and it's like not that that is
not that that's bad design but that i felt like i was being punished from playing the game i was
playing a few minutes before that now doing something differently and then when i would go back to going
to the enemies it would be like oh well now the enemies either they it's not that they aren't where
i want them to be it's just that they are spawning into places that i don't think are are are positive on
the game and so it's the actual getting to the bosses part of the game that bothers me not so much the
platforming or the uh the abilities of the player character i think we have a game that is like 75
percent there and the last 25 percent fall apart to just kind of be in that hidden gem category rather
than like must play territory yeah and i'll also just chime in and say that i i know that there are
little like cut scenes sort of sprinkled throughout um throughout the game that that sort of just sort
of mark your progress but if i i think if they did a little bit more of that and made it better like
the the highlight of the story is the beginning where they give you the exposition dump the rest of
it's just sort of there as sort of like a like letting you know that a new chapter is starting if they
did more of that and made it cool like almost ninja gaideny or golgo-y because the like the the
illustration style is nice and the story's got a cool hook and if they did more of that maybe i would
have been more like uh into this as an essential game but they kind of squandered a cool opening
yeah i can i can see that i i will say that for as far as uh well first of all i'm i'm fine with this
one you know this is not zelda 2 for me so i'm like all right you know i wanted it on but i'm i'm
okay with it not being on but uh but yeah i think i just had like the the the different feeling about
the level design than you did mike i i thought that the level design was great like i enjoyed
traversing through this game so i think that we yeah we just have like a we see it totally differently
for that for that part because for me the levels were almost as good as the boss battles like
like i like i i enjoyed the the platforming and like the falling not leading to your well like
yeah like the falling not leading to your death but yes it does lead you to like having to kind of do
some of it over and stuff but yeah i guess i just i guess i'm just trying to say like i never had that
feeling where like i felt frustrated by the enemy places meant personally like i have in other games
i think that's fair i think it's but you you kind of by just saying that like you reminded me of times
where it was like not only did i fall but then i would fall into like i wouldn't call them enemies
because you can't you can't defeat them but you would fall into like those moving spikes and so
you're like falling then being hit then falling down onto something else it's like it's like that
it's like yeah it's like an enemy you can't defeat and it's just like the wall you never just go
around the game punching walls and hoping that they'll open up shortcuts it's worth a shot it's always
worth a shot right things are still being discovered 40 years later in video games so it's worth punching
every wall in real life too it's all minecraft
every lawsuit solves solves solves solves
solves 배 배 배 배